You got any your interview?
Oh my God,
we're going to have to sit down.
She got a spectrum.
So you got people that don't even know if they're human or of live ingest.
Is this all the sedation because they'd been lied to so much for so long.
Then I know it's true.
And then over here you've got people that just believe whatever they see on CNN
and me,
I'm just trying to look at everything on while they've lot a lot,
but sometimes it's not that often times is incompetence.
What's real.
And so I don't blame it to editing.
That's like way over here or other people that are like way over here cause
they're trying to find some solace and believe there's order in the universe.
The truth is there's not order in the universe.
There's people trying to bring order to the universe and that's why they stage
events.
So they can try to bring order within that event.
And that's all I'm going to say.
What event are you talking about?
No Northwoods or Gulf of Tonkin or whatever the thing is or,
or taking a real event and making a big,
but it's not bad to question that.
And so how do we get convinced to say,
well,
uh,
you know,
I asked questions and I need to be shut down.
As long as I'm legitimately asking questions,
it is going to judge that I have that right.
So that's where we're all going.
Just what is the system?
We'll get rid of free speech,
right to self defense,
the family to fend those things and ask yourselves,
what are we about to than men?
I believe in that.
You can say that shit again.
What was it right to bear arms free speech and what was the third one?
Family.
What were the needs?
Big Sneezing.
John asks the question,
who was the big three?
Say that again.
I think mystery is what Ge,
I think mystery is what's key thing.
Now you get why and I appreciate you having me on guys.
My eyes don't want to be like,
my life is not sandy hook.
I'm said.
Yeah.
Tell me what you were telling me earlier that you were actually,
you even before all this happened,
you were planning your exit strategy.
Like you get weary of this.
Yeah.
And it's not like I'm afraid of the fight,
but I'm 45 and I've had a long adventurous life so I'd probably like 60 and I
was already like,
I wasn't sure about Trump or whatever has really bad feeling when he got
elected.
Not that he was bad,
just like all the worries about to start.
And then I was already planning to kind of face things out just cause I don't
wanna like Dow and I'm 55 a heart attack and the fact they attack me so much
makes me have to battle and fight and never give up.
And,
and,
and so it's not like they even wore me down before they ever,
they kept me in the game.
I explain it.
They kept me in the game attacking me in lying about me because now I'm,
we'll out.
I've now become,
when I was worried about,
now I dream about this stuff you that was what you were worried about initially?
Yeah,
because I realized about the four year,
five years ago,
but it's obsessive that I was already totally obsessed and you were telling me
that it fucks with your head [inaudible] certain amount of it after a while it
just fucks with your head.
Yeah,
the negativity.
Yeah.
And I like to have dreams.
I have like dreams are like 20 years long.
Like you said about DMT.
I'm a farmer and like it's a,
it's like 500 years ago and I'm just like planning things,
eating food and like put my kids to sleep and like,
you know,
cutting trees down and like walking around.
I like,
I have dreams,
robberies like normal and just being a normal person.
And so I,
I never,
I didn't like the global state.
Like they have like all these shows,
homeland,
all these shows her on this pick Damon,
I didn't like calculate what I was going to do and then I was already not ready
to give up.
I was ready to move on and innovate.
And now it's almost like it's God doing it.
I was like,
no,
it's not that easy.
You're going to be pinned against the wall by your enemies and you're going to
fight to the death.
And I don't believe God's a sadist,
but I realize it's God's plan.
I'm not going to be turned loose.
I wasn't just going to do a couple tours in this fight and beat be turned loose.
And so it's been,
it's been framed to realize that this is all big stage and God wants to see some
people dance.
But I tell you,
the globalist think they're like running me out or they think they've got me.
It's the difference.
It's like,
it's,
it's the opposite.
Now they've turned me into this maniac.
Well,
there's a,
there's definitely some sort of a struggle going on right now and there's a,
it's,
uh,
seems to be like a universal struggle for figuring out what people are and how
we should behave and who gets to decide that.
And there's certain universal truths are ignored and there's certain ones that
our emphasis over emphasized and there's certain ones that are,
you know,
that are in the goldilocks spot and we were working it out.
I think that's part of what's going on with human beings.
But when we have to be really,
really careful of is that by silencing some people and never giving them any
path to retribution,
we create internal enemies.
And this is,
this is what easily could be happening right now when someone doesn't have
ability to express themselves
because an evil force wants conflict.
And what you say is,
let me know.
It's an evil force,
but it's an archetypal force there.
They're listening to all those around them.
And there's a hive hive mind sort of thinking to a lot of this.
There's not a lot of debate about,
by the way,
let's just say this Joe and,
and to,
um,
10th plan.
Everybody else,
you didn't give into the pressuring of the threat.
It was more than nagging like a Shyrone,
like a bitching woman,
not against women.
But I mean,
I may not get it.
That's why us and so that's why you didn't have me on.
But then you realize I was just a shamble of you just trying to live the life
and put out good ideas and talk to people.
But folks are going to make you choose a shy and that's what's happening in this
quickening ish.
I don't want to choose a side.
Ryan Seacrest has got it nailed.
Nobody's coming to Ryan Seacrest for like political advice.
He's got it nailed.
He hosts a bunch of shows.
The real nice guys got a great smile.
He figured it out.
Yeah,
but you understand what that sweet spot man,
dummy you're talking about any,
oh my God,
he's leaving himself.
Entropy is stagnant water.
Oh it's still nothing's going on.
It's all clear.
It's dead and rotting.
What's alive?
Oh,
should big crashing waves.
It's seriously.
I've seen beyond.
Everybody has,
but I've,
I've seen way beyond cause you want to be in the conflict.
You want to be in the fight.
You want to take all your,
you're not successful Joe.
Cause you played along with the system.
You're successful because you did it organically and real doesn't mean it's
perfect.
I mean,
it's bad.
It was real.
That's why your success and then they come in,
you think,
oh,
I'm not saying you're bad.
I'm the same way.
Oh,
all these people are telling me how great I am.
I play ball with them because I've got,
you know this thing.
But they want you because they're soulless.
And so all I'm saying is you've made the right decision.
And I would just say having me on because I'm not perfect,
is deciding,
no,
America,
still America,
the world still the world.
We're allowed to talk about real things and hear rolled things because they want
to shut other voices down so they can lie about those voices.
And any idea that fears,
exposure or fears,
debate is a failed idea.